>> THE PRINCIPLE OF ROBB
ELEMENTA SCHOOL IN UVALDE,
TEXAS, SPEAKING OUT EXCLUSIVELY
TO CNN IN THE AFTERMATH OF A
MASS SHOOTING THAT KILLED 19
CHILDREN AND TWO OF THEIR
TEACHERS.
MANDY GUTIERREZ, WHO HAS BEEN
PUT ON PAID LEAVE, PENDING AN
INVESTIGATION, SAYS SHE STANDS
BY HER ACTIONS ON THAT FATEFUL
DAY AND THAT SHE FOLLOWED HER
TRAINING.
SHE ALSO SAYS THAT ACCUSATION
SHE WAS LAX ABOUT SCHOOL
SECURITY ARE UNFAIR AND
INACCURATE.
MORE TONIGHT FROM CNN'S ROSA
FLORES.
>> WHEN I WAS CALLING CHIEF
ARREDONDO, I HEARD THREE SHOTS.
THE INITIAL THREE SHOTS.
>> THE PRINCIPLE OF ROBB
ELEMENTARY SCHOOL IN UVALDE
BREAKING HER SILENCE AND
ANSWERING QUESTIONS ABOUT
ALLEGATIONS OF LAX SECURITY AT
THE SCHOOL.
>> I BELIEVE THAT I DID MY JOB
TO THE BEST OF MY ABILITIES.
>> WHILE ON FORSMAN'S HANDLING
OF THAT ILL-FATED DAY HAS SEEN
THE MOST SCRUTINY UP TO NOW,
THE FAMILIES OF THE VICTIMS --
>> THEY DON'T GIVE A DARN ABOUT
OUR CHILDREN OR US.
>> TURNING THEIR CARLES FOR
ACCOUNTABILITY TOWARDS THE
SCHOOL ADMINISTRATION,
INCLUDING THE SCHOOL PRINCIPAL,
WHO SAYS SHE WAS SUSPENDED WITH
PAY THIS, WEEK PENDING A FOR
PERFORMANCE REVIEW RELATING TO
CAMPUS SECURITY.
LAST SCHOOL YEAR WAS HER FIRST
SCHOOLYARD'S PRINCIPLE.
>> EVERY --
STARTING AT THAT SCHOOL,
[INAUDIBLE]
NEEDS TO BE GONE.
ALL OF THE SCHOOL BOARD MEETS
BEGUN.
>> I BELIEVE THEY ARE ENTITLED
TO THEIR OPINION.
I FOLLOWED THE TRAINING THAT I
WAS PROVIDED WITH, TO THE BEST
OF MY ABILITIES.
>> THE TEXAS HOUSE
INVESTIGATIVE COMMITTEE REPORT
REVEALED THAT ROBB ELEMENTARY
HAD A CULTURE OF NONCOMPLIANCE
WITH SAFETY POLICIES, REQUIRING
DOORS TO BE KEPT LOCKED, WHICH
TURNED OUT TO BE FATAL.
GUTIERREZ RESPONDING TO THAT
CRITICISM --
>> WAS THERE A CULTURE OF
NONCOMPLIANCE AT ROBB
ELEMENTARY?
>> ABSOLUTELY NOT.
ANY TIME THAT AN ALERT WENT OUT,
ANY EVERY SINGLE TEACHER AROUND
THAT CAMPUS TO TOOK IT TO MEAN
IT COULD BE A POTENTIAL
ESCALATING SITUATION.
AND SO EVERYBODY FOLLOWS
PROTOCOL.
>> SO, YOU DISAGREE WITH THE
FINDINGS OF THE TEXAS HOUSE
INVESTIGATIVE REPORT?
>> I DISAGREE.
>> ACCORDING TO THE TEXAS HOUSE
INVESTIGATIVE REPORT, A COACH
THAT WAS SOMEWHERE ON SCHOOL
PROPERTY, SAW THE GUNMAN JUMPED
THIS FENCE.
SHE USED HER RADIO TO REPORT
IT.
THE PRINCIPAL HEARD THE CALL
AND TRIED TO INITIATE A
LOCKDOWN USING A SOFTWARE
APPLICATION BUT THE WI-FI WAS
BAD AND SHE DID NOT USE THE
SCHOOL INTERCOM.
>> THEY COULD POTENTIALLY
MAGNIFY A SITUATION.
>> THAT'S THE DOOR THAT THE
GUNMAN USED TO ENTER THE SCHOOL,
ACCORDING TO THE REPORT, THE
DOOR WAS UNLOCKED.
HAD THE DOOR BEEN LOCKED, AS
THE POLICY REQUIRED, IT WOULD
HAVE LIKELY SLOWED DOWN THE
GUNMAN.
INSTEAD, SURVEILLANCE VIDEO
SHOWED THE GUNMAN WALKED INTO
THE BUILDING THROUGH AN
UNLOCKED DOOR.
WHY WAS THAT DOOR UNLOCKED THAT
DAY?
>> I AM NOT SURE WHY THAT DOOR
WAS UNLOCKED.
>> SO, THAT DOOR WAS NORMALLY
LOCKED DURING THE DAY?
>> ALWAYS LOCKED.
>> ALWAYS?
>> YES.
>> THEN, WALKED INTO A
CLASSROOM, WHICH WAS LIKELY
UNLOCKED, ACCORDING TO THE
REPORT.
THE REPORT ALSO STATES THAT THE
PRINCIPAL, TEACHERS AND EVEN
MANY FOURTH GRADE STUDENTS
WIDELY KNEW OF THE PROBLEM WITH
A LOCK TO ROOM 111.
BUT NO ONE PLACE TO WORK ORDER
TO REPAIR THE LOCK --
NOT THE PRINCIPLE, NOT ANYONE
ELSE.
GUTIERREZ DISPUTES THAT
ACCOUNT.
>> WOULD I KNOW FOR A FACT IS
THAT THE DOOR TO ROOM 111 DID,
IN FACT, LOCK.
>> IT DID?
>> THE TEACHER HAS TO USE THE
KEY TO ENTER.
>> SO, SOMEHOW, THE REPORT SAYS
THAT IT WAS LIKELY UNLOCKED.
SO, SOMEHOW, IT COULD HAVE BEEN
UNLOCKED ON THAT TODAY.
>> IT'S POSSIBLE.
>> SOME OF THE FAMILIES OF THE
VICTIMS SAY, ANY SAFETY LAPSES
WERE INEXCUSABLE.
>> WHAT DID YOU TELL HER?
>> WE FAILED OUR CHILDREN.
YOU FAILED OUR CHILDREN.
>> [INAUDIBLE]
CLOSE TO MY STAFF.
AND MY STUDENTS.
AND MANY OF THEIR FAMILIES.
IT'S AN UNIMAGINABLE PAIN, TO
KNOW THAT WE DON'T HAVE THOSE
INDIVIDUALS WITH US ANYMORE.
THOSE FAMILIES THAT ARE MISSING
THEIR LOVED ONES, EVERY SINGLE
DAY.
>> THE TEXAS HOUSE
INVESTIGATIVE COMMITTEE
STANDING BY THEIR REPORT, THE
CHAIRMAN ISSUING A STATEMENT TO
CNN, SAYING, THAT THAT IS BASED
ON TESTIMONY FROM MULTIPLE
INDIVIDUALS, FROM MULTIPLE
AGENCIES.
AS FOR THE SCHOOL DISTRICT, A
SPOKES PERSON DID RESPOND TO
OUR REQUEST FOR COMMENT.
BUT SAID THAT THEY ARE TOO SWAMPED
TO ANSWER QUESTIONS.